it's her the spark green diamond Rouge
I'm gonna use this word which was
totally not around 18 years ago when I
made this movie of a mass shot that
elephant love medley all the different
love songs all mashed together
publishing why you couldn't have done it
before nor oh do I have to bring the
actual artist I mean I didn't know Elton
John so I rang him up he said well
that's not a fantastic idea darling
course we'll get into it and then I
reached out to David Bowie and then Bono
and all these icons and they all just
thought it was a great daring idea the
trapeze moment that was something bad
wrote into the script given at the
Moulin Rouge Wildheart dance or
Disneyland for doll you wanted this
great entrance the director is a visual
of his birth question is always where
the entrance is an exit
you see Kabang and then you see the
flitter and then you see the silhouette
of her and then you see a body and then
you see the heart and then the very very
last thing you see is the eyes in the
face under the hat so it's very slow no
villains like the sparkling diamonds I
thought wouldn't be great for put in a
circus trapeze and we did a trapeze
number bobble has dumped it but Nicole
being the car was like no way she
trained with a circus person and when
you see her swing around that toe all
the way through that footage she's on
the trapeze she's being slung around
she comes down she falls into all those
guys though she was 100% stunt free on
that moment Nicole costume when she
first appears on the swing is called the
black diamonds outfit it was very
interesting all our discussion about
houses made Nicole this bicycle heroine
so Jim is a courtesan
she's not a street girl courtesan is
like a Geisha so you have to be very
likely now the characters 13 we kind of
mashed many other iconic characters like
that we wanted to maintain that 19th
century feeling of
corseted but at the same time we wanted
to call on a myriad of classical movie
stars
we knew Marilyn Monroe's costume in
bathtub of fish-scale Patton as a little
nod to her the look the reveal of the
face I mean at the totally Dietrich all
those elements melded together to create
the ultimate showgirl costume he was the
team I feel like wow it's already 20
years I mean that the affection that the
audience holds the title is it ordinary
there's like some child that are
conceived and grown up and now it's run
away and fall in love with an audience
and occasionally it drops by this hi dad
but it's got a lot of the time
[Music]